You're not going to believe it.
So come out, Nate.
Hey, babe. Hey.
Can you help me with something in the
bedroom real quick?
Yeah, sure. One sec. No, now, Actually.
Super fast. Hey, Matt.
Hey, just. Okay.
Hey. Hey.
What's going on? Yeah.
Jesus. What is it?
Just stay calm so I can show you
something real quick.
Okay. Okay.
I love Kelly Monroe.
It's not about her
Thanks, Lynette.
Police sources here have revealed that
the killer left something behind in
this alley. A blood soaked blue bootie,
the type worn over shoes by a variety
of home service providers.
LAPD forensics is working on.
Yep.
That doesn't. I mean, what are you
saying?
Did Matt notice the girl at the bar the
other night?
What girl? The--
The db, the dead body.
The girl that was murdered.
He left right after she did.
Oh, my God.
He followed her. Holy shit.
Oh, my God. Okay. Okay.
Matt showed up this morning with
scratches all over his arms.
What? Yes.
Yes. Big red, angry new scratches.
Okay. And he said his cat did it.
I don't think he has a cat.
Oh.
I'm telling you, it's Matt.
Matt is the West Side Ripper.
I know my killers.
It is him. And he is right there.
But he can't be.
It can't be.
Okay. Do you want. Do you want to just
go ahead and ask him? Because he has
the same blue boot. He says the killer.
He followed the girl out of the bar and
an hour later she was stabbed 37 times.
And then he waltzes in this morning
with don't kill me scratches on his
arms from his imaginary cat.
Okay, What more do you want?
I've hung out with him a dozen times.
He's just a normal guy.
Okay. Do you think Ted Bundy wore a t
shirt? I fuck.
Corpses. I beg you.
You got to stop listening to these
podcasts.
What are you guys talk about? How well
do you know him? What's.
What's going on with your little friend
over there?
What do you mean? We talk all the time.
What do you talk about? Just normal
stuff. Guy stuff. Like what?
He told me he's got a kid, and dating,
in LA, you know, it sucks.
He used to live in Pomona.
Pomona.
Okay. What do you say about that?
Anything. What?
What? What?
He said he moved to Los Angeles because
someone got attacked in his apartment
building. Shut up.
Are you,
Serious? Attacked in his building in
Pomona. Oh, my God.
Please. Okay, What else? What else?
What else was that? I mean.
I think it was like two years ago.
Two years ago. Okay.
Okay. Search Unsolved murders.
Pomona Apartment building 2021.
24 murders.
What the fuck is up with?
I've got to narrow down our suspects
here. Let's see. Unsolved murder of 82
year old Sharon Simpson. That's.
That's not a thing. He murders really
young, hot brunettes like.
Like this one.
Murder in apartment building 242 Work
Street where police found the victim.
Nicole Gibson, stabbed it.
That is the girl in the dress.
That is just.
Do Birdseye because he said that his
apartment building was next to some
tennis courts. Okay.
Birdseye.
Tennis court. You mean those tennis
courts? Oh, my God.
Oh, shit. Oh, shit.
It is him. I know.
He. He killed this girl in Pomona.
Now he's here. It's the Westside
fucking Ripper. I see he didn't find me
attractive enough to kill, but
whatever.
Oh, really? Really.
I'm just saying, I'm.
Sure there'll be other serial killers
that find you hot enough to kill.
Why would he just mention Pomona?
He just volunteered.
He's getting off on it. He is gloating.
This is what they do. I know these
guys. Btk, Zodiac.
They love to secretly boast that no one
can actually catch them.
Think about it. Think about it.
To the outside world, Matt is just the
toilet guy. But deep inside, he has
this secret. A huge, powerful secret.
I mean, can you imagine if they knew he
was the Westside Ripper?
Hey, guys. Hey.
Hey. Hi.
Hi.
Uh, sorry, I'm just headed out, But, um.
What did you want to tell me back
there, huh?
What was it I was gonna do?
Yeah. Back there.
I before.
When we were back there.
Yeah. Mm.
What'd you.
I have.
You know, it's crazy. I have no idea.
Oh, my God, babe.
No idea. He does this all the time now.
Worried?
Well, no. We'll get it. Work done.
Call the doctor for you.
Yeah. Get old like this guy.
Well, listen, in that case, I got some
bad news.
Huh? Yeah, boy.
The last hot water pipe is leaking.
Oh, look, I tried to patch it, but
we're going to have to change it out.
I just didn't.
Oh my God.
I don't want you guys to curse me when
I'm gone. You know.
You? We would--
The last person we would curse.
Okay, well, you know, I'll.
I'll pick one up. Bring it back
tomorrow.